[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i didn't have time to get the the camera
all right
hey folks welcome to the unity 2020
campfire i am very pleased to be joined
today by greg
ellis and elizabeth sweet elizabeth you
met on our last campfire greg ellis you
may be familiar
with from various places including um
my podcast the dark horse podcast i've
also been on his podcast he is the host
of
the respondent in addition to being an
actor a director
and the founder of monkey toes studio
he's also a an early adopter of unity
2020
and quickly becoming one of my favorite
people so welcome to both
greg and elizabeth
thank you brett it's a pleasure to be
here hi elizabeth how are you
hi great thanks thanks for having me
back brett appreciate it
so uh i thought i've had this thought
it's been hovering just
outside of consciousness for some time
but i've been thinking that in light of
the fact that we have chosen
the campfire metaphor and for those who
are joining us for the first time let me
just say that the reason
we speak of campfire is that human
beings for millions of years have
gathered around fires and presumably as
our capacity to discuss difficult
situations grew
people will have spent time around the
campfire exchanging ideas about
what is going wrong and what might be
done about it so it seems the perfect
thing
for for unity
so anyway what i had been thinking was
that perhaps there should be some fire
involved just sort of ceremonially
now i think i have suggested this too
late for greg to be able to get candles
into
his studio but as it happens greg i have
an extra one
here for you elizabeth i think you were
able
to procure a candle we do not need to
know how you went about doing that
we assumed that it was for a good cause
and therefore your means
were surely justified so what i think we
should do is just light these candles
i can say elizabeth you're not in
california are you oh you are in
california
can you do us a favor please light these
candles very
carefully all right i will all right so
i'm gonna light a candle uh this one's
for you greg
thank you brett i appreciate that yeah
no problem and uh i would just say
it is not an absolute requirement but
for people joining in the campfires
uh at home that it would be good
in the future if you
had a little fire you could bring to
bear yourself um
all right good i tried to use a match
but it didn't work so i'm using the
barbecue lighter instead as a backup yes
just in case it gets cold around the
campfire i did bring uh i did bring a
hat
um that i can put on i have a scarf it
needs to be and i got some english candy
as well
um which i can share um it's a bit bit
loud
you know english candy is uh in many
ways better than a lot of american candy
this is something that uh the english
take great pride in am i right about
that greg
you are you are spot on brett yes i am
i particularly love my english chocolate
and my crisps you call them chips we
call them crisps our chips are french
fries
it could get very complicated easily on
the campfire
yes i actually think chips is a more
charming term
and french fries is just an incorrect
term so
i don't know why we use that but but so
be it
all right well um i guess i should say
for those who are joining us
uh you should log into the
um democracy ai portal so that you can
exchange
information with us oh elizabeth has
something to tell us actually
yeah we're gonna do that in their
mission actually so um just hold off
there's a button below the screen um if
you log down to the
campfire.articlesofunity.org
um url and there's a button that will
activate at intermission so just stay
tuned
all right uh sorry i did not get the
memo i probably did get them at
memo and i probably did not read the
memo in time is what happened but uh
anyway
we will have you sign up at uh democracy
ai at the intermission but
at the moment i think the the pressing
thing for us to do is to talk about
where we are with respect to unity
uh what you all are seeing and uh
what it means so i i'm having
this uh experience which i'm sure
to some extent is being shared by both
of you
where there are a small number of people
that are
that really get it they understand why
unity is necessary and they're on board
and
as elizabeth is seeing close-up there
are
literally hundreds of people working
tremendous numbers of hours to make this
happen
and then we get a lot of interest from
people outside who
seem to be waiting for some indication
from the universe that
it is time to actually activate and
i guess i'm struck by the question
if what they're seeing on their various
news feeds is not triggering them
to uh to go all in with unity
what are they missing
greg do you have any idea well
gosh that's a that's a really good
question i think
part of the issue is that too many
people today act as if
no one can honestly disagree with them
if you have a difference of opinion with
them you're considered to
not merely be an error but in sin
um you're a racist uh
homophobe or whatever the villain of the
day happens to be
and i've talked to you about this before
but how do
we few
or maybe many um who who can who feel
like we can see
the inequities on both sides i i said
recently
that it each each convention feels like
there is this
message of um vote for us or die
vote for us or you will be dead this
fear-mongering
and um how do we
spread this message more how can we talk
and have the conversation
uh that that doesn't um that doesn't
deny someone
and and their existence or trigger
someone out of existence
and and listen uh to critical thinking
i'm i'm perplexed i mean i have a few i
have a few books that i
have a lot of books but there's a few
books here i want to just
share they're very simple small books
um you know the book of virtues benjamin
franklin the way to wealth benjamin
franklin rules of civility and decent
behavior george washington
common sense by thomas paine um
we can learn a great deal from from the
history of the past and the books that
we read
and um i think the word unity
is we should dwell on that for a moment
because
reunification and unity the unity of
what what are we unifying for what are
we coming around the campfire for
um it is for that community collective
it is to share stories
and to see if we can tend to the
familial
um broken tapestries of
this great country i've taught with you
before brett i love america
i mean i'd sing god bless america in a
heartbeat and
i would probably be vilified by people
or castigated as some
you know uh far-right republican-loving
um uh crazy person
and um we we just live in very
upside-down
tyranny the urgent times and i'm
i'm just pleased to be here i'm pleased
to be a part of the conversation
and um you know
further the discourse as to how i can
help how
people out there can help and how we can
all come together and
and be more of a collective there is
there is this restlessness i think in
the midst of abundance
um you know with this motivation to get
rich which is more about the excitement
of making money than it is about
wealth uh the desire for prosperity has
become an ardent passion
and it's the us and thems it's the
we're right or we're left with trump or
where clinton were
we're biden over trump and everything's
so polarizing
and i'm really concerned about
what yeah forgive me liz i'm just really
concerned about where we're at
with these two lesser evil choices
and to your point i'm sorry for
interrupting you um
but to your point i think that the
labels are often what are preventing us
from really
finding the collective spirit um we
we put these boxes around ourselves and
we aren't allowed and we aren't able to
get out of them and then we surround
ourselves with people who also are
comfortable
with those boxes and i think that a lot
of what we're missing
in american society is
is a tie to some sort of some sort of
greater purpose and some sort of
american mythology
uh joseph campbell is really um has has
impacted my life a lot and
his his stance on the need for
a mythological like uh some some sort of
mythology to really live by and to and
to aspire to the hero's journey is just
so important
for that kind of ability to see other
people in yourself
and to and to break down the walls that
that might have been put up around you
or that you or that you get comfortable
in so um i
i agree with you it's this it's the sort
of polarizing thing that we aren't able
to
to really get through because we don't
have a story
anymore yeah it reminds me of the oh
forgive me bro no go ahead
i just very quickly it reminds me the
phrase roll lock
so when we get roll locked um and a
loose definition that would be when
change dramatically when you break
through beyond your pre-existing belief
system maybe when you
when you leave the woke behind and
become more awake
but continue to be perceived as the same
person by your family
and those closest to you or others in
society
and i think we have to kind of unlock
this role
log so i
wish i had been taking notes because you
both hit
about six really important themes that i
think really are exactly what's going on
one of them the first one that you
you nailed here greg was this idea that
if someone does not agree with you
that they are the enemy right so i find
this
all the time and it's very perplexing i
cannot understand what goes through
people's minds
when they hear something that is
different than
their own perspective and it
automatically becomes
of a known type to them it is you know
i'm constantly facing being dismissed on
the basis that
if i'm not supporting biden for example
then that means i am supporting trump
and that i am doing so out of some sort
of defect of
character right that this is this is
this is about making money somehow or i
don't know what
but that that's such a small-minded way
of viewing things
and it blinds us to what i think is the
irony of
uh of the present moment at least
on the left side is there is a
misunderstanding
that if you love your country that you
don't see what's wrong with it
right so it's as if people imagine that
there's an inconsistency betw
between being a progressive and being a
patriot and i see no contradiction
whatsoever i want the country to to live
up to its
immense promise and that means both
seeing what's wonderful about it and
seeing where it hasn't quite gotten
there or where it's
fallen backwards and um
so i wish people would just
leave open a space for discovering that
there's actually a perspective
that isn't of some type they're familiar
with but that has some
meaning that they should be should be
looking for
and of course it's funny when we settled
on the idea of unity as a concept
you know it immediately resonated for us
for for very obvious reasons
but the number of other people who are
thinking about the same thing and the
number of places in history you know you
point to these
these books um that have a lot to tell
us and
this concept is resonant for so many
reasons at so many moments
so the final thing i'll say is
i think that people are missing
something very basic about
it is much easier to see what the nation
is not doing
for you than see what it is doing
for you and so this desire to tear the
place
down is predicated on viewing
only one of those two categories if you
think all it is doing for you
is uh mistreating you then the answer is
well you would lose nothing by tearing
it down
but the problem is the stuff that works
really well
is more or less invisible right
the the bad interaction with police is
dramatic
and uh you know spreads like wildfire
the normal interactions with police are
uninteresting and
so i i wish there were some
mechanism there of course many literary
tropes about teleporting people into
some alternate reality where they get to
see what would happen if their wishes
were fulfilled
i wish that the people who are so eager
to tear the country down
could see what the world would look like
in its absence and just have some
that it would just give them some pause
about what it is that they are inviting
because
it's clearly a disaster and we don't
need to make it happen in order to
discover that
and to that point i would say that it's
it's much more of a reactive
behavior than a responsive behavior
because if something
offends you or something triggers you
then then
you're you're immediately upset and it's
and it's really difficult to actually
address the problem and to see through
to the end of a logical conclusion um
you know you get sort of like blind rage
or it just becomes very upsetting and
instead i think that that that moment to
respond
that breath is something that we've lost
time for i mean the world is just such a
busy place how many notifications do you
get on your phone a day how many
scrolls do you do do you do on your
phone you know
um and there's and there's just very
little time
to reflect and to and to respond to
what's going on around you
i wholeheartedly agree with that and
that you know i've mentioned to brett
before the reason
one of the themes of the respondent is
how to be less reactive and more
responsible we are all response able
and it's no one person's fault no one is
to blame we are all responsible
and how can we come together um to tend
to this
i think you know to brett's point uh
about
the being able to see
uh into the future if you will um
or teleport into a time and place to be
able to see
where this is is leading um maybe that
wound
you know that those wounds the wound is
the place where the light enters you
and the scar is the heel where the
darkness leaves so perhaps there is
um it's a pre
cursor to what there may be some event
horizon
um you know i think we
when i first became aware of the word
woke
and when i started to see the the
the in a sense we're living in this era
of woke
capitalism in which companies pretend to
care about
pretend to care about social justice to
sell products to people who pretend to
hate capitalism
it it just
and you you just see it you see it
everywhere you turn on the tv
i mean i don't watch network television
i think i've
seen network television news maybe five
or six times in the last five years
because
it's sensational it's fear-based um
each side whether it be fox news or cnn
whether it be
the uh gop or the dnc
it's this fear mongeri and um
you know i'm i'm concerned about where
we're at uh in terms of
mental health particularly men's mental
health because i'm a man
and that's the lens i see through and
particularly with covid and the pandemic
and the panic demick
of um people this fear-mongering this
fear-based
storytelling that everything is well and
everything is troubling when actually i
think
some of it is i mean what we're talking
about it comes from a concern and a
curiosity of how we might tend
and meaning i think there's a crisis of
meaning and faith
um you know my understanding of meaning
is uh well i do say everything happens
for a reason we make up afterwards but
it's
it's ascribed subjective and nature is
objective reality and
and how we how we can discern between
what's a difficulty to endure and a
problem to solve
is important as well and that reactivity
that i see in mainstream media to your
point elizabeth
is so uh and has become
and is rising in amplification that it's
becoming this
um tyrannical cacophonous den
when any time a story hits
whether it be a police shooting or
whether it be
a group of boys at a washington monument
and uh squaring off or being squared off
with
that reactivity of this is what happens
i want to be the first i want to get on
anti-social media i want to
sh this this is a lynching this is
terrible
jesse smaller this is a lynching this is
terrible this is this is a publicly
all of that rhetoric is so divisive and
if you take a beat and you
just quell pay attention to what the
body's trying to tell you quell the need
to be reactive
and the impulse control you can maybe be
a bit more responsive when you do
respond or responsible
and in time you can see more context the
bigger picture the bigger story of
what's at play here within the media
with the ratings and the money and um
all of the
and i'm just i'm just so impressed with
what what the articles of unity is
has has been set out to do on the
journey
um if you will it's it's this big
relationship of people who've come
together
and and how impressive everyone is
working towards
a greater good for the republic if you
want to build a ship
you don't drum up people to collect wood
and then not assign them tasks and work
but rather you teach them to long for
the endless immensity of the sea
and america is so immense and it's so
vast and it's so wonderful that there is
so much good and positive and great
stories out there i'd love to hear more
of those
i'd love to see more of those on the
news so
um in the spirit of campfire uh
i'm having a thought a new thought and
i'm not sure it's a right thought but
in response to what you have both
suggested people are missing
i'm seeing a picture in which
they're really missing two things
there's a vision
of what might be that i think
the three of us and everybody else who
is on board with unity
would love to show people who are
at the moment involved in this uh
i don't know whether to call it a it's a
slow motion train wreck but it's also
this
this faulty drama um it's a
it's a false fight and i think
uh the other aspect of it is that the
parties
all of the people who are involved in
the fight the one that you mentioned
at the top greg where when somebody says
something that just doesn't fit with the
script that you're on
then you know they are the other thing
and you fight them as if they were
you know a pathogen or or a predator or
something like that
that that polarization
is it is turning everyone into useful
idiots
and if unity is something it is
a movement of people who are opting out
of the useful idiot category
and you know this is um it's a difficult
thing to do because you will be
portrayed as out of touch
or worse you'll be portrayed as doing
the bidding of the greater evil as we've
certainly talked about at length and
that's of course
not at all what the movement is like on
the inside
on the inside it's decent people and
it's
people who are highly diverse and who
roughly
share a sense for where the country
should go it's not
uh the same in any precise detail but
i i have the sense that
we cannot seem to escape the problem
that we are being demonized for a reason
and the reason is so that we can't be
heard and the reason that we mustn't be
heard
is that if we were hearable it's so
intuitive that you would want to be part
of the unity movement that
even for selfish reasons that which one
has to gain
by being part of a movement that is
resisting the nation being torn apart
in this partisan battle is immense
so of course you would as soon as you
get it you want to be on board with it
so
it is very important that it be
ungettable and
um i guess there's just a
there is a fight that you might be
having with somebody
and then there is a fight that you are
induced to have with somebody
for their purpose and not yours and you
and the people you're fighting with
are actually not antagonists but you are
being
placed in that role because it is
necessary for somebody else's well-being
and i really wish there was some way
unfortunately i think that message will
be all too easily understood
by people who already get it and because
of the content
we know why people who don't get it are
so hard to reach with it
so how do we escape that is there is
there an out
gosh really good question how how
is there an hour
i don't know is the honest answer i mean
there's doubt there isn't there
and from from my view what i see is this
this polarization and you know
mainstream and social media
is so seems to be so ideologically
fixated around
identity politics that most public
heterodox free thinkers that i see will
be
or have been excoriated cancelled
um belittled
unheard is that a word
so how to break through how to
you know it's almost like you you it
feels like i've mentioned this to you
before as well brett the the
heretical illuminati you know for me i
see people like you
and and many other people like you um
as modern-day philosophers confronting
the
this recent and it's and you know i
talked with heather mcdonald recently
and i said recent and she corrected me
that it's been decades long in the
academy
uh recent radicalization of left-wing
politics
um and you know these eloquent
emergent truths of this devotion to
wisdom this
how do we how do we position people
whose voices we think should be
amplified
and maybe they do have an area of
irreducible rascality and maybe they are
out there um great let's see
let's hear more voices um more moderate
voice i know it's a
an overused term what's wrong with being
moderate what's wrong with mediating
through
um moderation rather than polarizing
through extremes
i don't know the answer i'm curious as
to
how we might do more of it that's why
i'm here is to just kind of lend my
voice and see how i can help
i also do not know the answer um
but i think i think part of part of the
issue that i see especially when i talk
to people about unity
is that we're not ready or it's not the
time
and it's something that i've reflected
on a lot um
and i don't think that we're ever really
ready for the things that are most
important to
our lives and to the like fulfillment of
our lives
you know one of the most um impactful
things that either you
do or happen to you um you're never
ready for
but there are you do have the skills and
you have
you have other other tools in your
toolbox that can help you get there and
that can help you
make it through that and so i think a
lot of the
the readiness is or the the lack of
feeling ready
is the is a fear at the end of the day
and so that's why fear-mongering works
so well
is because it preys on that lack of
readiness around that lack of perceived
unreadiness
and it you know it has its way in it and
it doesn't let you
feel capable um to do the things that
you need to do
and to join you know to to make a
difference
so i i agree with these things but i i
feel like i'm
watching a tragedy and i don't mean i'm
watching a tragedy unfold i mean i feel
like i'm
almost watching a scripted tragedy where
i know what happens what happens is
people become
motivated to do the thing that they must
do when it's too late
that's what's going to happen all right
people will get it they will definitely
get it but they will get it when it's
too late
and so at some level how do you say
there's no such thing as not ready
because what's coming
is coming at a rate right there's a
question about whether
you will act and
be able to alter what's coming or
you won't act and then you will
experience the downstream consequences
of whatever it is
and people don't get the rate the rate
is
incredibly fast and i mean you know just
even what we saw last night in wisconsin
right this is you know
we're watching something that looks like
a civil war now it's happening very
locally
it's happening as a result of an event
but um it does give us a hint
of what's down the road if we don't
figure out how to recognize each other
and so really the point is it's
there is no ready or not ready you are
equally ready for both outcomes the
question is which
path do you want to take it's a fork in
the road and
to take the standard fork is to allow
processes
that you've now had a chance to see
unfolding continue
and to take the other fork is to risk
the unknown definitely
but given what you know is progressing
why wouldn't you risk the unknown right
it just
it doesn't make sense that you would um
you know that you would
uh head off the cliff because
you're afraid that if you take the road
that doesn't head off the cliff
the answer might be worse and the answer
is it could be worse but
falling off a cliff is a terrible thing
right the chances that the other road
actually goes somewhere
is enough that you should take that risk
so you don't
have the guaranteed uh falling off a
cliff phenomenon
this this reminds me of an old adage
that my my father used to say
um when you come to a fork in the road
pick it up
i believe that's that's yogi berra who
uh
when you come to a fork in the road take
it it was what he said i think but
um anyway yeah well
i mean the other thing is look uh
i think those of us on screen here
and those who have been on previous
campfires begin to tell another part of
the story
because i think we're facing the same
disaster as everybody else
but i feel like um
we actually are doing okay we don't have
a
you know other than the plan that we
have deployed we don't have some secret
escape mechanism from a catastrophe
where the nation comes apart
and that's scary but i've got to tell
you i think there's something
to the sense of stability
that arises from just simply discovering
that there are a lot of people who see
the same picture
and that they are actually interested in
doing something about it rather than
just
spectating the disaster so i i wish that
one of the things people would grasp
is we may not be able to do anything
about this
right that's a fact on the other hand
who do you want to be with as this
unfolds
do you want to be with people who are
actually interested in taking a risk and
trying to do something new and different
and
averting a disaster or do you want to be
on one of the teams that is causing the
disaster
uh as you know a group of useful idiots
of one side or the other
right to me it's just a slam dunk
i agree i think uh i think planting your
flag
and saying this is this is where i stand
this is i have you know this is my
integrated sense of self this is what i
believe in
and um i may not have the answers i may
not know where this is leading but i
i'll be damned if i'm going to look back
and say i never took a stand
that i'm i'm just choosing to go this
route because
this is the lesser of two evils i i
don't want orange man bad
trump derangement syndrome i have to go
far left i
biden is is not cognitively there
and i'm not a fan of harris so i'm gonna
go right
well that's just left and right zigzag
so and you're on one side or the other
and i think you know people have said to
me
it's been tried before and the third
party or the third ticket
i think we refer to it as so
and they've also worked it's not like
third parties have never worked i mean
i'm not saying this is a party
it isn't it could become one but that's
not
what it is it's a plan um but
third parties have succeeded and
the thing is it's also true that there
are lots of patterns that you can find
where something has no precedent
and then it happens and it does have a
precedent so
given the unusualness of the moment the
fact that this doesn't sound like
something you've seen work before
doesn't mean a damn thing yeah i agree
i agree and i think you know that there
is a lot of fear that you know i keep
coming back to the fear there's a lot of
fear i think there's a lot of
um uh
fear-mongering a lot i think there's a
lot of depression i think many people
are suffering right now everyone's
everyone suffers with something whatever
that is
um and many people living lives are
quiet desperation
um i see the the suicide rates rising
it's divorce rates rising there is just
this
and conversely at the same time
we're actually i think you know in terms
of in general
we've i i hesitate to say
we've been living through uh peaceful
times
for the lasso but relatively speaking to
the stories that i heard from my
grandparents and parents growing up
um you know we we
i don't know there's this the sense i
people have mentioned to me recently
depression there's a
there's this almost like this depression
of america's personality
and that deep rest of depression this
dis-ease
of of america and um the
the how do we address our national unity
um you know and
and that might be a touchstone for
reversing common feelings of
depression in the common collective and
making people feel more positive and
and moving away from from hateful to
grateful
and i think this virtual space is moving
businesses from gray to green from
suburban metropolis and
urban environments to to the nature and
wilderness and the countryside so i
think there are there are obviously
positive things going
on but um all i've seen of the
conventions
literally on both sides was a simple
simple message of vote for us
or die they'll kill you oh they'll kill
you
or you'll be dead they didn't handle
covert we would handle it better and it
just goes
it's it just goes up and up and up and
what what good is that and it's fueled
by the mainstream media
it's fueled by no go ahead no please go
ahead brother
i was just going to say um it's
really unpatriotic it's anti-patriotic
and this is the thing that is hard to
get that all of the flags
involved and all of the claims of
patriotism are clearly
hollow because anybody who wishes to
demonize another american right
now are there american demons there are
but it's a small
number right most of the people who are
doing the harm
misunderstand where they are right they
may be
being misled by somebody who may
themselves be
uh confused or may in fact be up to no
good but
parties that want us at each other's
throats
that want to use your hatred of other
americans as the reason
that you should put them in power so
that they can then sell that power they
can pedal it to the highest bidder
that is unpatriotic and so
somehow it is
impossible to make that point because
these parties have branded patriotism
they've co-opted the idea of patriotism
and so
i think people have lost touch with what
it actually looks like
right and that that's what you know
that's what unity is about and
um we must hang together
or surely we will all hang separately
right we're not talking about a literal
hanging in this case but we are talking
about
the same phenomenon and um
it's just if only there was a way
to get people to just step out of their
mindset
long enough to listen with fresh ears
we'd have a much better shot
so brett you said this earlier in the
show
that patriotism doesn't mean that you
love america without any sort of
uh qualms or that you know you just
think it's perfect
um and i know that we've we've talked a
lot about the definition of patriot and
patriotism so greg i'd be really
interested to know
what what you think a patriotism you
think patriotism is
um beyond beyond just the nationalistic
sort of confines that it's usually
placed in
well you know i haven't i i being
english of birth i love
my country of origin i love being
british and i love
the englishness of the english and um
you know i'm also american i have
american citizenship and i love being
american i love being a part of i love
being a patriot
um for me when i came to america i was
invited here
to work and i had the distinct honor
of being invited to sing the national
anthem
at uh i think it was a new york rangers
game a hockey game and then an oakland
days game
i remember learning the national anthem
and i was very
i actually kept getting one word wrong
every time i rehearsed it while i was
rehearsing the day of singing it um i'm
not going to mention how i got the word
wrong but it was quite embarrassing
um but i loved that who's bro i think it
was whose
broad stripes and striped bras i kept
singing in rehearsal
and um i think it's you know america
i love the sense of pain that sense of
patriotism that
rises for the national anthem i love the
the baseball
game americana hot dog family tradition
of the seventh inning stretch
i love that sports um um
that that that hurrah we can win
we can beat anyone um aspect but i also
love that
that down home cooking of the south i
love the the different complex cultures
and the rich uh breadth of history
whether it be
when i went to um uh birmingham alabama
to the civil rights museum and
uh the baptist church across the road
and meeting the homeless people there
and
whether it be the the great native
american indian i don't even know we're
allowed to say native american indian
anymore that's how the words
i don't care choctaw cherokee
um skiddy all all of that mythology and
the code
of um of the indians and
um there's just so the food that like
it's so much about america
that is to be championed
and cheered and um
the the greatest i mean where was this
this little book here
i mean even this little book which you
know it's called the constitution of the
united states
it's an amazing read you know the
the that time
george washington and what he brought
together to
to put together that document i marveled
the first time i
read that that document and
how these men
people from a different era came
together
to set this great experiment and i think
america is a great experiment it's it's
a fresh new
nimble massive experiment that
everyone's come together in and it's a
melting pot of so many rich wonderful
cultures and
languages and and um religions and
spiritualities
and peoples and i think you know
i i don't want to go back to it all the
time since may i'm maybe not answering
your question elizabeth but
we're in this position because from my
my perspective
i keep talking about identity politics
or identity politics
um i think we're in this position
because in its current form it is a
collective ideology
uh it doesn't value the individual and
and one of the things that i love about
america is this this notion of
this concept of the american dream you
know
anyone can come to america and make it
and particularly in hollywood
you know you can you can be homeless one
day and then sell a script for a million
dollars the next
um and identity politics doesn't
value the the individual for the content
of his or her
them or they character but instead makes
prejudicial assessments on the basis
of race and gender and sexuality and
religion and
in the name of anti-racism identity
politics has rehabilitated racial
thinking
you know i grew up in a small town in
northern england there was one
family that had a darker skin tone than
me
and it was the pigmentation
i didn't look upon anthony wife as
um you know any identity
he's just my mate he's just a friend
he's just someone who
when i got out of line he head-butted me
and we had a little fight one time and
you know it was
it was it was anthony but you know this
this positioning of identitarian you are
who you are based on on what i perceive
or identify you as or how you
it's it's so it's so counterintuitive as
well to me because
american is that place where you can
america is that place where you can come
and you can
your dreams can come true and nightmares
too
um and i that's why i love this movement
this movement of
unity the articles of unity that says
you know what we're actually
we're not going to just rant from one
side about the other we're not just
going to complain
and and so it's been tried and it's been
you know what
we are going to try we are going to come
together and i know from
look andrew yang who who bret you know i
was a supporter of and still am a
supporter of and i got behind his
campaign
did i realistically know that he had a
realistic chance of winning no
did i believe he would win no if i'm
honest i didn't believe he would win
given the current system
did i believe in him and was i willing
to take
take a stand for him and support him and
speak for him
and plant my flag and say even though we
may be defeated
uh this is who i stand with yes and i'm
willing to do that
every single time now and if i'm
cancelled if we
if it doesn't succeed who defines what
success is anyway
so i want to address a couple points
that you raise
one i think we're a little bit confused
about the collectivist
aspect of the the woke
movement because there's nothing really
wrong with
collectivism right not there is a
collective aspect in fact unity
appeals to a certain collective desire
the problem is the de-individuation in
other words
we have a collective nature and we have
an individual nature and they're both
very real and they're both
very important and any movement that
negates either one of these
you know if you're so died in the wool
libertarian
that all you see is the individual and
you don't understand that there you know
you believe that self you're a self-made
person and
the people you respect are all self made
well then you're not understanding
how we actually got where we are so it's
the tension between these two things
that's important
and the de-individuated one is
particularly frightening
you know the most frightening movements
in history have been
predicated on a de-individuation that
turns people into
cogs in a machine in a way that's
extremely dangerous
the other thing i wanted to say is that
i think that this
issue of you know patriotism isn't just
nationalism i think
you said elizabeth i think there's
actually a very clean
distinction we can draw and i don't know
whether it is
what he had on his mind but i think jfk
actually did this one very
uh clearly ask not what your country can
do for you
ask what you can do for your country and
to me
what your country can do for you you may
love your country because it does such
wonderful things for you
and that's nationalism and your
willingness to sacrifice or to take
risks on behalf of your country that's
patriotism
and i think that's where we are is at
this moment
the country desperately needs us to take
risks and to pay costs on its behalf so
that it can continue
why would we do that because so much
depends on its continuing i mean in fact
it's not just americans that are
depending on it it's the world
right the role america plays in the
world is vitally important which doesn't
mean
that we always get it right in fact we
have gotten it wrong many times
but the overarching impact
has been very positive and so many
nations have
followed us right the constitution which
you mentioned greg
was a model for the free world and
um to undervalue
what was accomplished here and then to
destroy it
because of uh what isn't right about it
either what actually isn't right about
it or what is perceived to not be right
about it
it's just such a gargantuan waste
i agree i i agree with you too
and i think though about
people who this country hasn't served
and so
when i do get into arguments or
discussions about patriotism and you
know
loving america and whatever way that is
um
it is hard to
try to put myself in the shoes of people
who
have really not been served um by this
country at all and to
and to and to appeal to them in a way
that that really gets to them because
i think that that's something really
profound that needs to be addressed
and i don't know how to do it
well i think the thing is we do know how
to do it and we were on the path
and i believe progress stalled which is
part of where the frustration is coming
from but
the objective the right objective was
always
equality of opportunity all right
equality of opportunity
is a vital concept it is the proper
objective
it needs to be understood through
properly sophisticated eyes in other
words you're never going to have
a system in which there's no nobody ever
experiences bad luck
but the bad luck has to be distributed
randomly with respect to things
like race and sex so
that objective was the right one and
unfortunately
it has now been supplanted by one
that a will never work and b is going to
create
an absolute dystopia right equality of
outcome is an insane objective that will
take
all sorts of human values and it will
just bulldoze them and
um so in some sense i think when
when when somebody challenges
the demand for equality of
outcome they are heard to be desiring
inequality in a permanent sense and
somehow we have not managed to compel
people that actually many of us
in fact the great majority of americans
are committed to the idea
that the right way for the country to be
structured is to have
opportunity as broadly distributed and
as equally distributed as possible
right it's it's rare that i meet anybody
who doesn't agree that that's
the desirable state for the country
isn't that america isn't that what
america
that's what was the america i i moved to
25 years ago i mean
so do you think i'm curious to know from
both of you do you think that sometimes
people talk about
equality and it's this declarative
definitive place where if they actually
took a moment to listen with curiosity
and had the discourse because i remember
i remember when i
when i didn't fully understand you know
the
equity of outcome versus equity of
opportunity when i had the first
discourse about
privilege and earned privilege and
unearned privilege
and it wasn't a collar-binded uh
discussion
and to understand just the ramifications
of equity of outcome
that's we want to live in communist
china
i mean that's what that is you know i
i i talked with um greg hurwitz this
week
uh on on an episode of the respondent
and we talk about uh equity of
opportunity
and equity of outcome and um well we're
going to have an olympics where everyone
finishes the race at the same time where
everyone gets
the same color medal the same no i mean
that's
obviously a trite bland example but you
know
do you think either of you that some
people just that they're just
it's rallying cry as they're marching oh
we want equality of everything
well um you know it's funny when the
evergreen
situation was happening i had this
student
who you know as the thing was unfolding
she
had been there in fact she's in uh one
of the videos the first video that
became famous from that
that whole incident standing with me
this is a black woman
and anyway as the whole thing was
unfolding she
said you know there's this kurt vonnegut
story you have to read it
and i was of course not paying attention
to things i had to read at all and she
was very persistent you have to read it
and um finally she persuaded me that
there was something in it i needed to
read and so i did the story is harrison
bergeron
and it is basically just simply a
thought experiment about a quality of
outcome and the
the absolute dystopia that
it produces right and she was absolutely
right that this was
this was the core question um
so i think the thing is people are just
they're not thinking and they
detect that something is wrong but they
have understood
what is wrong incorrectly and so that
they are having kind of an allergic
reaction against the
um against a
fiction and unfortunately they are
credibly
going to tear the country apart and even
if
i think unfortunately
the the woke
side is actually very likely to drive
the
country into the arms of the
other party which is going to be
dragged towards its worst impulses by
the fact that we are now going to see
each other as
racially defined in other words that was
something that never went away
but it was going away over long periods
of time it's now
back with such a vengeance that um
you know people have been told that they
are uh they're demonic because there's
white
they're white it's a kind of uh sin that
they inherit it can't be
dispelled and so
um they are gonna begin to see
themselves as white first
too and you know it's not to say that
there weren't people who saw it that way
all along but
the question is the mainstream is going
to start seeing things
in those terms and um
it's dystopias either way
yeah go ahead yeah greg you're so your
question also
took me back to university um so no i
didn't go to evergreen but
i definitely my university was um
this is what we learned we misdiagnosed
the problem and
and everyone got really upset about the
wrong
thing it seems uh looking back and i
mean i personally subscribed
to um very far left ideology for
quite some time uh i have some good
friends who brought me back
um but it's it's really difficult when
everyone around you
is is yelling about something that you
can see
is a problem but it's not the problem
and
that's i i mean that's what we see with
biden and trump
right trump is the problem he's you know
when we get rid of trump the country's
fixed well that's absolutely false
um but it works because it's immediate
it's immediate gratification and it's
like this is what you do and this is the
outcome and it's a b
c but there are many more letters in the
alphabet
so um oh go ahead greg
no no i was i i was i'm curious um
you know when we when we talk about
patriotism
you know what you said brett is that
that really
speaks to me in terms of um this
the difference between patriotism and
nationalism
and i'm not going to suggest what the
difference is but to me
patriotism is that combination of
different feelings relating to and when
i say different they can be
you know aspirational and advocational
they can also be disappointed and
and let down in in your country but that
that
that that ethnic cultural political
historical
all of those those myriad of areas that
you can
you can you know you can speak up about
and to and say look this this i have an
issue with this
i've got a real problem with this and
right now i have a real problem with
america and it's this
and it's the both the political parties
that's the issue i have
and i'm going to speak out about it well
how am i going to speak about it i'm
going to go on here i'm going to
now some people may say he's got nothing
to say i'm not interested in it
so what um you know get involved
have have a voice uh i think there is
there is something to you know someone
once said the world we perceive as a
dream we learn to have from a script we
have not written
and and and perhaps that ideology is so
extremely rooted um
you know to your point elizabeth i have
a friend of mine who's a
ceo of a very successful company and she
was very
radical and extreme and woke and it was
conversation and discourse
over a long period of time that um
we conversed and she began to
come back from the extreme and and so
much so that she started to go towards
the other extreme and i'm like
be mindful to go the other way he just
he doesn't have to go the pendulum
didn't swing too big
you know all right i think i've got
something it's so
obvious really but uh it feels right to
me
yeah um
the question is which of uh you'll see
what the the wrinkle is here in a second
but
the feeling of patriotism that we are
hunting
around here is very close kin
with the love that one has for their
children
right you can be livid at your children
right for something that they have done
that is terribly wrong it doesn't mean
you don't love them doesn't mean you
wouldn't
jump in front of a train to save them
right
but the point is those things are
completely consistent
right you want your children to do well
you want them
to shine you want them to be the best
people they possibly can be
and if they're being the best people
they possibly can be then you can be
proud as hell and if they're screwing up
you can be angry as hell but the point
is
these are they're different axes right
your love for your country is not the
same thing as your belief that it is
doing everything right and in fact this
is one of the things
you know it's i i find
trump one of the most difficult
presidents
in history to listen to right because
he's constantly telling
us how everything we do is the best as
if the fact that it's us doing it
makes it the best right which is a
non-sequitur at best
um and anyway i i just
so the idea is there's something about
the familial love
that has the exact characteristic where
your your love for
your family does not change because
you're disappointed in them right i love
that
yeah i love that i was i was actually
thinking that before about 10-15 minutes
ago about that notion that
you know if you have a partner of you
i'm sure heather at times has been very
upset with you
it doesn't mean that she can't er exp
you know she still loves you she's going
to express her disappointment or are
upset and
that the unity that's there that that
that that bond
that love for each other for the
collective
you einsteins uh hangs
is is it still remains it endures
and you know critical thinking how can
we think
critically um and i i just love that
relational ship that we're all on
together
you know we're all we're all in this
together in little microcosms and how we
how we can just you know what america
gets on my nerves at times america just
goes on and on and on and it's like
americans just oh gosh you're so bright
and loud and
the fluorescent lights and the and
everything's an extravaganza
and oh you know i could go on and on
about the things that
at any given moment of a day if i'm
having a hard time
i could be grumpy about america ah damn
america you're getting on my news
you know but other times
i love you america come on listen
giddy up now you know oh man
[Music]
yeah um i totally agree with you
here's the tragedy though and i i'm i'm
hesitant to even say
this but the other day i was uh
i was in some part of town i don't know
very well and
i was walking by a park and there was a
black family a large black family like
20 people right i don't know if it was a
reunion or what but
and they were having a barbecue in the
park and it looked
so familiar and hospitable
and in any previous year
i would without hesitation have walked
through
the part of the park that they were in
and i would have
commented to them on the beauty of the
day or how nice the
party they were having looked and i know
what would have come back because it
never fails
you know people they they like the
camaraderie of a stranger
recognizing them and it feels good every
time and
maybe there's even something a little
bit extra when somebody is you know
from some different lineage and yet
you're part of the same
family and i looked at the situation and
i just thought
i don't know if that thing that never
fails would fail
now right if are we at a place where
because i'm going to walk into the
situation and i'm
white that there might be suspicion of
me that's
not my experience of the place and yet i
know that that is
if it's not true today give it another
six months
right and i just felt there was so much
tragedy
in even having to have that thought like
i wouldn't have had the slightest
hesitation
in a past year but we've come to a place
where that sense of being
in any way part of the same story
on the same team whatever it is that
causes
strangers to be able to smile at each
other and have a positive interaction
and know that there was no subtext right
that thing is being lost at an
incredible rate and
frankly i'm angry about it right we have
a right to that
how angry because your anger expressed
is not
um it's not as amplified as many
people's anger are out on the streets
going
i mean you're you're you must be angry
enough that you you
you've you've you've started a would you
call it a movement brett i mean would
you call this
hopefully i mean it's a small one i hope
it becomes a large one i don't know that
it needs me
but um yeah i think i triggered
something or maybe i landed on something
that
was you know ready to happen and so gave
voice to it
but um but
yeah i'm i am angry at anything that
wants to tear us apart and
it doesn't mean that i think hey we're
great as we are
i think we have a lot of work to do but
god damn it tearing this apart is just
insane
it's not going to be good for anybody
yeah
i've been i've mentioned this to you
before i've been astounded at some of
the images i've seen
in you know being an artist and seeing
statues works of art
even even if they're perceived to be
egregious pieces of art in a contextual
historical time
by a particular artist or to to
champion someone that people now look
back on like
that's the lessons of history that
they're
you know i when i saw in my own country
winston churchill's statue being defaced
and people urinating on it and trying to
tear it down
this is a man who it could be argued and
i know it's
his his history has been rewritten in
the last few years
apparently um that he single-handedly
or at least led the he was the voice of
england during the second world war and
really was that leader that stepped in
love him into work but he had his issues
and he had like like most men all men
he helped save the nation and and helped
bring together the
the allied forces to help defeat true
nazism not the neo-nazis we refer to
today as the alt-right and the
um you know anyone who isn't radical
left
so i i've been more perplexed
than angry but there have been times
when i've been angry
um and what's so surprising about
those events and when that happens is
why are we
why are we taking down churchill instead
of diving deeper into
who else was there that made that happen
because you know it wasn't just that one
man he had a whole team of people there
were so many people doing so many other
things
that allowed for that to happen let's
tell more stories
instead of taking down one and then
silencing the others
well i would say i would say it a little
differently i would say that the
the key thing is warts and all
right like let me confess i have a
problem
with the celebration of christopher
columbus
this one gets me i don't i don't
resonate with it and let me tell you why
the fact of christopher columbus
is an absolute catastrophe for
american indians right
now that doesn't all belong on
christopher columbus's plate
but some of it does and
the fact that we would celebrate
christopher columbus as if he discovered
america
you can't discover a continent with 100
or 50 million people on it or something
like
that right so a there's a
fiction in the story which is that he
discovered it what it really means is he
discovered it on behalf of europeans was
which was a catastrophe for another
population of people who are
now americans so i don't i don't like us
celebrating something
that was a disaster for one of our
member populations the other thing is
it's a nonsense myth that wasn't his
name he wasn't christopher columbus he
was cristobal cologne
so the fact that we're writing a myth
for the perspective of
i don't know conveying it to children or
something it's all kind of
uh nonsensical that said
we ought to be teaching what cristobal
cologne did
and didn't do and how he ended up doing
it it's a simple
factual story and the fact that that
factual story has an important relevance
to
what america is is something that's
unchangeable it just
simply did happen and it changed history
and
so you know in the case of churchill
there's good and bad but the good
changed history
for the better it was important right
you will find the same thing is true
for martin luther king jr right if you
want to
find only the warts he had him but did
he change
history for the better yes did he
frankly i think willingly give his life
in order to make this a better country i
believe he did
and so you know i'm comfortable with a
warts and all
uh discussion of anybody including me
right i don't
want to be mythologized i want to be
dealt with with my flaws and my
strengths together that's that's the
only picture that makes sense it's the
only one you would want to teach because
it's the only one that gives anybody any
basis to know
what to do with the information right so
i think the thing is is history a matter
of self-serving myths
or is history a description of what
happened that has
nuance and complexity that you have to
grapple with it has to be the second
right the former if we treat it as a
mythological space that we are allowed
to paint
uh in a way that reflects well on us and
badly on others
then it just ends in a war of all
against all which is where i'm afraid
we're
headed
what's interesting about mythology is in
in greek and roman times is that
it is good and bad and a lot of it's
really gnarly and it's not just people
who are
who are doing the best in the world and
i don't know they're like doing all
these great things it's like
really crazy stories of people
sacrificing a lot
and failing epically and then
maybe redeeming themselves maybe not but
that's what we learn from we learn from
the mistakes and we can't be perfect
no one can be yeah no nobody can be
nobody is
you know churchill martin luther king
gandhi
they're human beings are flawed and
there are tensions within every single
human being so
um let's i don't know stop mythologizing
i guess
all right greg did you have something
you wanted to say i was just gonna
mention
uh i you know i wholeheartedly agree
with you about chris
christopher columbus you know in
hollywood we have chris columbus
who's a film director and producer and
screenwriter some may know him for uh
directing mrs doubtfire and some of the
harry potter movies
um and home alone um and
uh i didn't know about the history
of christopher columbus or more of that
rich history of christopher columbus
and that's i think one of the lessons is
that we're always
we're always we should always try and
strive to be open to learning something
new
and if i learned that from you for
example brett and said
you know what i still i disagree with
you i still want to celebrate
christopher columbus and have a day
named after
you have every right to do that get
educated first a little bit on the
history
and the you know what actually happened
who this man was how we remember him
why we remember him the way we remember
him
you know and how we might rewrite some
of that history well i
i want to i want to push back a little
bit because i agree that you should have
the right
to celebrate what you would but i
believe that at the same time just as
you have the right to say anything
there are certain things you should um
you should decide not to say
because it does harm right so i guess
what i would
uh what i would get at is
there are
if i celebrate christopher columbus or
if i improve it and i celebrate
cristobal cologne i'm celebrating a
tragedy
for some americans i don't think i
should be celebrating anything that was
a tragedy
for some americans which means
you know i don't i don't want the
confederacy celebrated i certainly want
it understood
it doesn't mean that there weren't you
know people who were patriotic to it who
had laudable
characteristics but i don't want it
celebrated because the confederacy was a
catastrophe
for a population of americans
and maybe this is just part of what
unity is about
it's about the recognition that we're
not going to
we're not going to pretend anything
didn't happen right
but that the things we celebrate should
be things that we can all
celebrate right and um
i'm not saying that that's the correct
resolution but it feels
it feels right to me and
you know i mean i think in some sense
this is built into the fabric of this
country
why do i celebrate benjamin franklin
he's not my ancestor
couldn't possibly be right but
he is my cultural ancestor
right what benjamin franklin represents
is something
that has descended through history to me
and something that
is laudable and something that i believe
should be universal
we should all feel ben franklin doesn't
matter your skin color doesn't matter
you know what your faith might be ben
franklin was a great thinker and he was
a great american thinker and
we americans are in some sense descended
from him irrespective of when we arrived
and
by what mechanism and so
i don't know i want i want a vision of
unity in which
we bring everyone in on the good stuff
that can truly be celebrated by us all
and where all of us recognize the
horrors of those
features of our history that you know
were a win for some and a loss for
others
and on that note brett i think that's a
perfect segue into
um bringing the audience to the
conversation and so
after intermission we're gonna use
democracy ai and we um we can ask you
the audience some questions and one that
i
ask or will ask is what um what can we
celebrate
about america and what is worth
celebrating now
um so greg brett if you have some
questions um
on your mind right now that you'd like
to ask the audience we can also talk
about it in your mission and then we can
announce it after
um that would be great
i'd like to ask people if they have
talked
to friends and family about
unity and what has been
if they can characterize the response
that has come back i'd be very curious
to know
what happens when people have tried that
greg you have anything you'd like to ask
i'd be curious to hear the answers to
that too
um i would i would ask
what what drove people
to connect with unity how did people
connect with unity was it uh
was it the message was it was it um
the was it bread was it the voice was it
a particular podcast was it an episode
what connected how did people become
connected to this because
i think this movement this amplification
of this moving is really
is really something it's really
impressive what everyone has been able
to put together
um i i'm just so i don't i don't know if
there's two people or 2 000 people or
how many people are out there
i i'm just impressed that that this
is happening at this time
in american history all right
so we are going to take an intermission
you if you have not done it already
should click the button at the bottom of
the screen is that right elizabeth
um a button at the bottom of the screen
that will connect you with democracy
ai and when we return after is it a
15-minute break
is that right elizabeth knows right
yes 15-minute intermission 15-minute
intermission all right and then we will
uh
sort out some of what we learn and
hopefully it will generate some more
questions
and um in the meantime uh
be well and we'll see in 15.
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and
[Music]
so
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to our fifth
unity 2020 campfire with greg ellis and
elizabeth sweet
we are at the interactive q a
portion where we are going to use this
amazing tool
that has been uh provided to us
to interact with you the audience and
find out what you
are experiencing what you know what you
desire
all of those things so um elizabeth i
think i'm going to hand it over to you
as you have
the uh the console that interacts with
democracy ai
what do you see i do indeed so
um we asked the audience to ask us a
question
first um while they warmed up and
answered the questions that we asked
or yeah to answer the questions that we
asked before the intermission
so the question that had the highest
percentage agreement
from our audience using democracy ai is
an interesting one
um what key
campaign finance and voting process
reforms
um not i'm not sure
i understand this not first past the
post are essential to save our democracy
can you guys shed any light on that one
yeah they're asking for
what kinds of structural alterations we
would want in order to fix the
democratic process so that it is less
prone to
capture and to polarization
things like that and so um i'm a little
hesitant to be specific here and i would
just point
to the fact that the unity 2020
proposal itself demonstrates
that there is a way within the confines
of our existing structure
to do something that functions
differently the
fact of creating a an agreement
a power sharing agreement under which
our candidates
will be drafted that demonstrates that
you don't actually need to alter the
structure
structure of the constitution in order
to change the way
it functions so how many such
alterations are there that one can
envision
where one doesn't have to
take a scalpel to the
structuring of the the rules of the
nation in order to
to alter where we end up i don't know
how clear that is but my point is i
don't want us
to limit ourselves to thinking that what
has to happen here
is some kind of uh constitutional
convention or its equivalent in order to
fix
how things work sometimes a little
imagination is what it takes
thanks um the next question that we have
is i think we should move
up sorry i think we should move
i think we should move this movement off
the internet
how do we engage locally should we start
crowdfunding
um those seem to be two very different
questions the movement can't move
off the internet it can begin to do
things that are not on the internet and
i very much hope that will happen
obviously kovid makes that really
difficult
um because gathering in person is
obviously
something that carries a certain amount
of peril hopefully that clears up soon
don't know when it will
in the meantime we may be stuck with
various kinds of
internet phenomena um i'm not sure why
the funding question is linked
to that all i can say about the funding
is that there is
um a world of possibilities that is
opened up by substantial funding and
then there are
a great many regulations and
hazards that accompany having the
funding and that one should not
plunge into it without looking
first at the sum total of phenomena that
you'll engage with if you do so
but anyway yes engage with people
directly
it doesn't it this is not supposed to be
a top-down
movement this is you know campfire is
chosen as a metaphor because people
gather around campfires and
you should take embers from our campfire
and start your own and
gather people and help them see what you
can see and figure out what they have to
teach you
and sing songs of unity are we supposed
to sing around a campfire
we get later after a few toddies right
well that's another thing that we i
wondered whether or not it would set the
right or the wrong tone if we were to
share drinks around a campfire probably
it would be uh an appropriate thing to
do and we should consider it for future
campfires
but yes songs definitely yeah maybe
maybe we just don't don't drink the
kool-aid
um in terms of uh in terms of
for me campaign finance reform that's a
huge thing
i think the system has a real conflict
of interest right now real and perceived
and it results when members seek and
receive uh
campaign contributions one of my
particular areas
of agitation or advocation is
in marriage and family breakdown
when i found out that the default shared
parenting
law which has been introduced in
minnesota and arizona and kentucky
to reform family law had only been
passed
in kentucky and the reason it was passed
was because in kentucky the state
legislature cannot be lobbied by law
firms and attorneys and family law
practices
i think uh personally i i think the
breakdown of the family is the
single biggest civilizational
catastrophe we might be facing today
and perhaps the greatest indicator at
the root of america's
torn familial tapestry is marriage and
family breakdown
social ills and public policy stem from
the health and well-being of
relationships and family formation
and that personality um of
america which seems to be disordered uh
somewhat
is um it's rooted in that
that lack of cross-partisan um
relational ships and relationships and
how
people talk and discourse across the
aisle so
i think taking some of the money out of
um family of promoting
family breakdown it would be huge
and i think uh obviously the
pharmaceutical industry there were so
many industries and
um campaign finance reform for me is is
a big one
well so uh campaign finance reform
has long been a signature issue for me
but i
almost wonder if we
uh it is important but insufficient at
this point there's a
earlier moment in our history where
campaign finance reform might have been
sufficient to
to right the ship of state but i i think
that
time has passed but i would point out
that this is actually a good example of
something that could be dealt with by
structural reform
one that is actually hard to imagine
because there is so much money in our
political system
but it could also be dealt with in some
other way that doesn't involve the
formality
which is to say people could stop
electing
politicians that take money from
corrupting influences
and this is something you uh
do not require anyone's permission to do
and we've in fact seen
politicians who have pledged to raise
only uh money below a certain dollar
amount for example
so there are many ways to uh to get
there the necessity of taking
money out of politics is absolutely
clear i would say it is a corrosive
influence and
the frustration in the streets is very
much a consequence of the fact
that policy is now almost completely
decoupled
with the uh the public will and the
public well-being
the public has very little influence
over policy and it has left
um it has left people angry and
legitimately so but
they have they have lashed out in a way
that is
largely incoherent
[Music]
do you think there are go ahead
elizabeth
oh i just wanted to add to the um to the
to the family metaphor
that we were actually talking about in
the first half
we talked about children and really
relationships to children and
relationships to spouses but we didn't
touch on the relationship to parents and
i think that's something that's really
lost as well
is this um is this sort of breakdown
of parental trust uh and i
i think that that is something that we
are living through right now is this
sort of this
the this hatred of of the system and of
history
and of the past and i think that um
i don't know this is getting way
metaphorical and theoretical and you
guys were just bringing you back down to
earth so
um we don't have to go down this route
but uh i agree with you guys
the hatred of the patriarchy don't get
me started on that
so that yeah i just i just i just wanted
to raise that point but you were saying
i'm sorry
no well greg was going to say something
i just wanted to
um point out that there is something
uh well below the level of governance
there's something
corrosive about advertisers
seeking to induce desires in young
people because it gets them to spend
money
that this is actually interfering with
the natural parental
relationship and i don't know what the
outgrowth of that is but one of the
things that may be
emerging as you point out elizabeth is a
distrust of the past
may have something to do with the fact
that there's been
a force for its own economic reasons
interfering
with the relationship that one
generation has with another
and uh it
i don't know what relevance it has to uh
our movement and our
political objectives but um but
certainly it's something that needs to
be thought of in the larger context
yeah i think it's a really good point
that you make elizabeth
one of my areas of passion is uh on the
respondent is
families in the familial bonds and how
uh
they seem we seem to be tearing down and
breaking down the family
um and and you know
brett and i talked about on the dark
horse podcast we talked about
boys in particular and um you know the
motivational factors driving the growing
epidemic of unmotivated boys
video games and teaching methods
prescription drugs
environmental toxins devaluation of
masculinity that's the big one for me
why are we why have we been why have we
allowed
the conversation in social and
mainstream media to devalue
the the image of man and the patriarch
and the father figure
and if we if we don't speak up and speak
out
about that then we are devaluing all of
our families the the collective
tribe um individual and collective
so i'm fascinated with that particular
area and how
how we can come together around the
campfire we can break bread we can
get to know our fellow man woman child
mother father from different cultural
backgrounds different
different ethnicities um recently on the
respondent i brought i brought
extra what's considered to be extreme
member of um
antifa and and the proud boys to bring
them together to have a conversation we
need to bring the extremes in from the
cold and have those conversations so
that
people feel less out there
you know um and and i think that
that boys and men and fathers
and daughters and mothers how we can
begin
to really for me
the policy change i i understand what
you're saying but it's it's extremely
difficult
because people do feel disenfranchised
um
from policy and from with the big money
in in politics and and changing policy
but
when i when i see the legal system
not reforming itself because it's
incentivized to make money from the
breakdown of families
that's a huge issue for me that's a
catastrophe
that we need to to tend to because our
future generations are
growing up without leadership and
guidance and mentorship and role models
uh i agree i think um family is
essential
and it's under attack from multiple
uh sides one of them being the one you
point to another one being
the explicitly anti-familial
message in the blm movement and
what i would say though is that we are
overdue
for a kind of sober renegotiation
of um the agreement between the sexes
for example
that there is something about the way
history has unfolded
that has placed different burdens on
men and on women and there is
room for a
new and more modern take which is not to
say
that one throws out all of the things
from the past because some of those
things frankly aren't even about
what it is to be human we inherited them
from an even
more ancient past but um but
what i want us to see is preserve the
stuff that works the stuff that
is out of date may need an update
and what we should do is we should seek
the
um the renegotiation that
retrieves the best gains for all
involved at the lowest cost
it's about time we had that conversation
which we can't in the context of
uh motivated reasoning about familial
destruction or anything like it
and it's interesting one of our um one
of our audience members
echoed or said um or excuse me
articulated almost exactly what we're
talking about here in response to the
question what drove you to connect with
unity2020 which i believe greg was your
question
um this person said i'm afraid of trump
and biden and i see the collapse of
civilization
right around the corner and no one seems
to see it or care and this is the part
that really speaks to what we were just
talking about
almost every aspect of our culture has
become disgusted and depraved due to our
market culture
and so it's this overpric it's this
prioritization of the market
over people over families
i would say yeah that's a
really good point i think it's no way
hyperbolic to say that american society
in the western world as a whole is in
the grips and has been in the grips of a
culture war and the society the seismic
societal rumblings under our feet um
have been knocking us off balance for
quite some time
and we need to re-center ourselves and
get
a firmer footing and um
it seems it seems to me that no matter
the issues surrounding rhetoric and
debate
has had this shrill um panic based
let's talk about the panic damage an
overwatch intensity that's
unprecedented whether it's me too trump
racism mass violence immigration
or so many other issues and concerns
and um there's this growing chasm
between
opposing sides and it's just grown wider
and wider and wider
and and this this to me articles of
unity is
daring you know it really is very daring
and we need some daring do in america
america is known for daring do
for people who take risks and um
that that daring to express an opinion
that conflicts with a given prevailing
orthodoxy
um oh we might be subject to ridicule
and personal infective
so let's have the debate you know
um you know it's it's
it's true that most vicious skirmish
skirmishes involve
these these soldiers from the front
lines who are
battle battle-tested
social justice warriors and everyone's
fighting for that
that that piece of the the commodity
commoditized communicative um
media pie um um
so how do we how do we break through
what that daring do is
the articles of unity like it's here
it's not
it's not a pipe dream it's happening
someone tweeted
tweeted to me uh the other day uh well
that
you know like andrew yang had free
andrew yang well that ship sailed and
that ship sailed and well no way it
hasn't it's sailing and we're all on it
we're all on this beautiful experiment
it's america so
get on board and see let you know get
involved
i totally agree with this people have so
many rationalizations for why
they don't want to do something
different and uh
boy if there was ever a time to get over
it now would be it
so elizabeth go ahead yeah i just have
one more
one more response um from one of our
audience members that 76
of the rest of the audience agreed with
and it speaks to this perfectly
i agree with the ex i agree with the
assessment that this country is in peril
i haven't previously been politically
active but i feel that this year has
given me no choice
i feel it's my duty to rally to a cause
that could return us to the path of
progress
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah no
hell yeah every word i mean that's it we
are in peril and
we we are left with no choice and if all
the people who are telling you that we
are making the wrong choice
they have not yet understood that they
don't have a choice but to
do something different that as you point
out greg
involves peril but so what
that's where we are yeah i i
wholeheartedly agree it's
sometimes i am astounded that people
don't see that there is no choice
it's already been like you and i talked
about it
months months ago i saw what we we're
not choosing
the dnc's made the choice they're not
making the choice
they made the choice and months ago
yep like okay it's going to be joe and
it's going to be camelot and
we know what the choice is on the other
side so we don't have a choice
this is a choice and
have a voice you have a choice
and it's a unity ticket
i do wonder why the
parties get a pass with respect to their
responsibility
i mean you know there's no shortage of
people who will come at any effort to do
anything new
and accuse it of inviting danger or
you know being implausible or being
about something else
but the parties announced to us
that they are ready to roll the dice on
the future of this country they're not
worried if they were worried they'd
sober up but they're not sober they're
you know they're having a hoot so
it just seems to me at the point that
your parties
announce that they have no interest in
leadership that they don't really
care about risking
a an empty four years when we can least
at least tolerate it then they do leave
us no choice so
they acted as you point out greg and we
are responding because
that's what one would do rationally
well there was i guess so
speaking of rationality um in response
to the question
what about unity resonates most with you
our most agreed with answer with 74
of audience agreement um has two points
number one the promotion of more
rational less emotional thought
and number two focus on bringing the
heat down and letting the light take
over
yep excellent right bringing the heat
down
you mean this this is so much it you
can't have a conversation because you
get there and it's like
instantly the judgment about what you
represent and
what the right answer to it is
everybody's so damn sure of themselves
so uh yeah that's a very good answer you
said 77
agreed with it 74 and then the next
uh most agreed with the answer was
respecting other opinions and finding a
common unified way to work
together despite differences wow
absolutely yeah i think yeah
we're so much stronger together than we
are separate into
different areas come they
take the blinkers off see what's going
on
see what's been going on for so long
and and and wise up wake up the woke
and just just listen with curiosity
to to what's going on that's all just i
i agree wholeheartedly with what you
know people are saying and the responses
and
it's what it's wonderful to have it's
wonderful to be a part of this and to be
a part of the discourse so thank you for
having me
thanks for for doing this um i would say
listen with curiosity you said and i
would add
generosity if you will
assume if do don't assume the worst of
what is being said the worst possible
interpretation
see if there's not something in what
people are saying that you resonate with
and then
have the courage to say i agree with you
this far
here's where i think we disagree you'll
be amazed how
far that formulation will take you
i love that assuming you're having a
real conversation and not one in which
somebody has decided you're a villain
and they're going to defeat you because
that's the only way the universe
continues which
you are a nasty villain and we must
cancel you in the moment i will not hear
a word of what you're saying
i would pull my moustache and i shall go
away
and plot your demise exactly
it doesn't usually come perfect phrase
that way but
uh but yeah that's approximately the
tenor of it
what else do you have elizabeth you see
other uh answers you'd like to tell us
about
um yeah i've just i've moved on to the
next question um what do you want to
celebrate about america
and um there's there are a bunch of
answers that are tied actually 75 and uh
the first one that pops up
is our ability to bring cultures and
people together
and evolve culturally from them
america's ability to adapt and
self-reflect and improve
as a means of celebration and i think
that's i think that's beautiful
um you know it's about integration
not and yeah it's about bringing people
together and and
having you know um bulgogi tacos is like
such a
such a fun thing to to think about it's
like you
you you have korean food and you mix it
with mexican food and you have this
really
kind of strange thing but it's delicious
and it's fun and you
it's it's about bringing people together
really
yeah and culturally together i think
there's something very deep
about this and um i'm a little
embarrassed it took me so long
to even realize what it was you know
i've been an american for my whole life
which is
51 years and i've been studying human
evolution and
in particular patterns of human history
and pre-history and i know that people
battle
on the basis of lineage identity that's
one of the things that human beings do
the thing that's really special about
the country is that it aspires to do
something different
it aspires to collaborate on the basis
of
the fact that it is profitable for us to
collaborate
even when we are not close relatives of
each other and
this is the tragedy of what's happening
is we are actually
losing that and we are defaulting to an
ancient mode
that is detestable a mode in which
we fight people because of something
they had no choice about
right who they who they are at the level
of their immutable characteristics
it's such a stupid thing to fight over
that that's your genes in charge
and if there's one thing i've learned
from studying evolution
you don't want your genes to be in
charge what they want
is uh arbitrary a lot of it's immoral
and the fact that america aspires to
something better
and that the free world followed us
because what it aspired to was so
beautiful and so desirable
that it was irresistible how can we lose
the courage of our convictions now it's
just a terrible error
yeah and i would look i i echo that turn
the lens
on on with some of the celebrated
aspects of what brought us to where we
are today
how we've survived and moved from
survival to thrival
and celebrate the celebrity of america
you know there is so much good going on
in america so many good people that
that connective tissue that cathartic
sensorium of all these different
ethnicities and cultures and
the fact that i'm allowed in i mean i
you know it wasn't too long ago there
was a tea party in boston
apparently and um
we're all we're all um we're all ragtag
and
from somewhere else and from you go far
back enough that
this is the beauty of the campfire you
know the next one we'll have to have
some
some virtual s'mores and um i'm gonna
get you singing
brett weinstein oh absolutely i love
seeing it i should say
it is a beautiful thing but the fly in
the ointment
of this campfire is the word thrival
which
i absolutely categorically reject i
let's sing a song called survival to
thrivals
rival let's reject the word because bret
rejects the word
no i i will not go along with rival but
everything else you said
i resonate with that is just the one
word
it was that one word i'm i'm not going
to be able to get past it you know that
may be a personal defect i would accept
that interpretation but nonetheless i'm
not going to budge
well i've come out with a few different
aphorisms
change is painful and pain pain is
changeful is changeful a word does that
pass
out that one works for me you know well
enough
well enough but uh all right elizabeth
what do you have for us yeah i've got
i've got another really good one so
let me remind us of the question what do
you want to celebrate about america
this person says liberty i want gay
couples to protect their marijuana with
ar-15s if that makes them happy
it's powerful the ar-15s are powerful
as is marijuana now that we've
concentrated
i'm getting high or i'll shoot
yeah um yeah that's a look i don't want
them to have to defend it with ar-15s
but otherwise i'm on board
with that view um shouldn't have to um
um and we can we can close this question
with this answer
uh that we don't come from the same
place literally or metaphorically but we
agreed to work together to be in a place
worth living in
and dying for
yeah i love this um
you know a couple of years ago like
literally
maybe two years ago i said something
about
patriotism on twitter and
i got this pushback that there was
disbelief that there was any patriotism
on the left
and i know what it was about because i
see a lot of
tearing down of america and minimizing
its accomplishments and things like that
on the left but i
also come from a tradition that is
patriotic and does
want to see the country live up to its
potential
and i feel like i don't know
hopefully the unity movement has had
something to do with it but i hear
people
wrestling with their own subconscious
and discovering
that they actually are comfortable with
this um this patriotic
collective view of what we are as a
nation and what we might be
and you know i hope we accomplish more i
hope we
find a way to recapture the white house
but whether we do that or not
seeing people find each other and look
each other in the eye
on the basis of this shared
understanding
of what we are um is
very heartening so i'm enthusiastic
about
about the fact that we you can even hear
that in the responses to these questions
very clearly i think
yeah go ahead
oh um i was just gonna move on to the
next question that i think
uh brett asked what do friends and
family say when you talk to them about
unity
and unfortunately it's a little less
positive than we might have hoped um but
uh the top answer was that most people
say it won't work
i've been able to get through a few and
they joined the movement
um so people are also looking at this
like a movement which i think is good
for
you know sort of the long-term vision of
what what we deserve as americans
um there's a lot of skepticism that i'm
seeing here
in in the answers they don't feel safe
with the idea
um and yeah a lot of
it won't work and i think that this
speaks to
sort of the frames and mental models
that we that we create
and that are and that we live in um it's
really hard
to to walk outside of those and to
imagine something that's
never happened before that we've never
seen um
but i think it's possible i mean it has
to be possible
right well the other thing to say is um
the self-fulfilling aspect of saying
that it's not possible
is a little bit hard to get past if
you're in the movement because it
absolutely is possible
it may not happen why won't it happen
because people have told themselves that
it's not possible
why do they tell themselves that it's
not possible in part because the parties
have made this very difficult
and they have assured you that anybody
who
would think about possibilities like
this is either stupid or a traitor
right you're electing the greater evil
or
you're just too dumb to get why it won't
work
and um
the fact is it either will work
or something else will eventually work
or we will die from it not working
right we will tear ourselves apart
because
people lack imagination to see another
possibility when the other possibility
i mean this isn't like somebody is
asking you to
literally go charge a hill with a
machine gun nest on it
this is a question of being willing to
confront
parties and tell them no and vote
right that's very simple and it's
comparatively safe
but um the parties have done a very
effective job of convincing people that
there is no other way
and to that point um the
the top so the fourth most popular
answer was um
most are receptive but doubt it's
practicality the politically disaffected
are the most receptive
and i just want you all to know out
there that over half of the people
participating
are politically disaffected as they uh
highlighted in the onboarding questions
so
we're we're here i mean
we are receptive like this is this is a
home for you
if you are politically disaffected or
you feel like you don't belong on
either of the side of the aisle um you
you belong here
you belong in unity so this is
such an important point the parties have
played a cynical game
because they don't care whether most
americans
vote for them what they need is enough
americans to vote for them that they
have power that they can then sell to
the highest bidder
that can be a tiny fraction of americans
so they have played
a very toxic game because it doesn't
matter to them that they have turned off
most americans
to the questions of governance the fact
that unity seems to bring
so many people back into the question of
how
are we to live is
very heartening and we're
unity to capture the attention of simply
that group of people
the disaffected it would be the largest
uh movement
in the country and so um
maybe this is really what the parties
are telling us is
that those who uh are partisans
are going to be unreachable because
they're robots they've been programmed
not to be reachable
that's their mechanism for never having
to deal with real competition
but that the the fatal error is that
they have turned
so many people off that if those people
can be alerted to
the fact that there is something that
can be done um
then in the end we will win
i think we've already won there's more
winning to be had
i mean part of the i get the goal and
the purpose the end game
but i also think that that that you know
maybe there are disaffected people who
who have found the articles of unity but
i also think there are people who
who will begin to find the articles of
unity
that are in either one of the two camps
that will just be
drawn to a conversation that isn't so
toxic that isn't so
shame rage cyclical it isn't
human kryptonite of it's us or them
and if you're with you're not with us
then you're with them and
there's got to be um multiple
hidden bonuses and positives to to a
conversation that
in is inclusive rather than exclusive
hasn't that oh absolutely i mean and in
fact many of the
disaffected reside inside the parties i
i was one i still am one
i'm a registered democrat and i've
described myself for a decade
as the world's most reluctant democrat
why
because i see the game why don't i leave
the party
because i want to vote for andrew yang
and tulsi gabbard
in the hope that they can eventually
outfox the dnc but do i expect it to
happen inside the democratic party
i don't so anyway i think a lot of
people
see it that way they're in a party
because they have
in an absolute sense somewhat more power
there but that power never
manifests anything the dnc is exhibited
ample capacity to shut down anything
that would represent positive change
um i would say trump defeated the rnc
and he has now taken over
their party so that's at least a
different story even if not necessarily
a hopeful one
but but yes the disaffected reside
outside of the parties and inside of the
parties and
they are the ones we must reach
so i think one um one final question
that i think would be really good to
to send us off here is a question from
the audience and the question is this
how do we get this movement talked about
in the media on large platforms and
outside
of and i'm adding this last part but
outside of
maybe the the spaces that are controlled
or
tightly monitored by the parties
yeah that's a great question and in some
sense
um i think we have to open our eyes
there is a force that doesn't want
change
why because it's the way things are
structured is very profitable for it
it not only controls the parties but it
controls our
media sufficient to prevent
movements outside from gaining hold we
have seen
that the control is weakening bernie
sanders
showed that it was weakening donald
trump showed that it was weakening
uh andrew yang showed that it was
weakening tulsi gabbard showed that it
was weakening
and so i think the point is we have to
defeat it
it doesn't have to let us in but if it
doesn't let us in
it's telling you something about its
commitment to discussing
things that are important and uh if
you're paying attention to
alternative sources then you know that
there are certain stories that never
show up
in the mainstream media and that that
has something to do with
a desire to keep on script rather than
to admit what's actually taking place
and you know if you had somebody in your
life
that was committed to you not knowing
important facts about
things that were going on in and around
you you would exclude them
because you would know that they were up
to no good and
in this case that's what we have we have
a malevolent force and it's very
unpatriotic
and it doesn't have our well-being at
heart and
we have an obligation to confront it so
i would say
it'd be great if we could gain access to
the mainstream media but
i don't think we should expect them to
let us in and their failure to do so
is evidence that we have to go around
and there are plenty of alternative
places that we can go
it's just a question of whether people
will tune into them
i'm curious brett when you if i may when
you talk about mainstream media if if
you were to
pick a show or a a
an outlet or someone to sit down and
talk with
who if you had the choice to pick
who would it be who would you sit down
from mainstream media and break bread
with and share
the story of the articles of unity
it's a good question i mean i've you
know i've gone on fox and i've talked to
tucker carlson about it um
you know he is more open to these things
than anything on the
the left side but i would say this is
really up to them
you know the new york times doesn't like
this idea
why doesn't it like this idea because it
has a very clear sense of keeping you
know it
the new york times has gone from being
the paper of record
to being uh like a set of blinders
right that just keeps a certain kind of
voter from
seeing things that would disturb them
and
i i wish i knew the answer to your
question but but the structure has
become
so corrupt that uh i'm waiting for
somebody
inside of it to break out and make
contact and say actually
we see it too i don't think it is
necessarily sensible to
point to particular voices there and
expect them to respond because they
won't
i hear you
all right was there more elizabeth
no that's that's all i got all right um
any final thoughts greg
final thoughts i believe that
that that there is going to be a
breakthrough with mainstream media i
believe that that there are already
people there i think there are
there are more people aware of the
articles of unity than perhaps
we realize and i think the message
spreads far and wide and propagates
in ways very difficult to
to track and keep the metrics of and
success what is success how do we define
it
i'm i'm i want to say thank you to
everyone who's tuned in and
has watched i want to thank you
elizabeth
for um you know
allowing me to be part of this and brett
thank you for the invitation
it's marvelous to join in the discourse
and be a part of this this
movement and this ticket and um i
i just encourage people to listen more
to help it grow get involved and yeah
i've had a lovely time wonderful i must
say i am
filled with admiration for you both as
well
as i think i said last time the greatest
part
of being involved in the unity movement
is discovering
all of these marvelous quirky patriots
who are really
committed to saving the nation in spite
of its
worst instincts and uh anyway
i i salute you both and thanks for
joining me
and uh let's uh move forward
as you might say hell yeah weinstein
hell yeah
all right bye guys bye thank you
good night good night be well everyone
three two one there you're live
hi hi everyone we forgot to mention to
hit campfiresmores.articlesofunity.org
to connect with your fellow patriots now
and digest this episode and talk more
about what we can do to bring unity
closer to you and your family
and your community thanks and have a
great night
foreign
i
do
you